أقف الآن خارج
مسجد مانشستر المركزي ، هؤلاء
هم أول لاعبين جمعة
يحتجزونهم منذ وقوع الهجوم ،
هذا مجتمع أكثر مما شعرت به في بعض النواحي
تحت الحصار ، شعروا بالقلق لأنهم
شعروا بالخوف من الخروج ولكن هناك  هم
أشخاص آخرون في المجتمع يقولون لا
، لا يوجد سبب للشعور بالخوف ، لذا فإن
إحدى القواعد المتعلقة بالدخول إلى المسجد
هي أنه يجب عليك خلع حذائك ،
وهذا ما سنفعله
الآن.  أقف مع إمام
المسجد ، لقد ألقيت محاضرة عاطفية للغاية
اليوم خطبة اليوم ، أعني إذا كانت هناك
وجبة جاهزة واحدة تريد أن يعرفها الناس
مما قلته اليوم ،
فما هي
جملة بسيطة وليست كلمات
النبي المبارك.  محمد
مؤمن إذا كان شخص ما يحافظ على
سلامة جميع الأشخاص الآخرين بخير ، لذلك فقط عند
المدخل الأمامي للمسجد ، أردت فقط
أن أوضح لك هذه العلامة ، حيث قام شخص ما بوضع هذا
مع علامة تصنيف يتحول إلى الحب ومن أجل
مانشستر وهناك بالفعل  الأشخاص
داخل المسجد الآن
بقمصانهم وعلى ظهر ذلك القميص لديهم
علامة تجزئة تقول إنني أتحول إلى الحب لقد
تعرضت لعدد من الخسارة لأنني
لم أر أبدًا أشخاصًا يحملون هذا النوع من
العلامات وأعتقد أن هذا  علامة مشجعة
تظهر أن الناس هنا يتمتعون
بالمرونة
وأنهم يشعرون وكأنهم جزء من المجتمع الأكبر والأوسع